he's really cool he didn't really mind
he asked me to take out a couple things
and I didn't really do it I kind of left
them in any way but you know I sort of
make fun of him i have a whole chapter
in the book about british men and how
kind of hopeless they are and how
emotionally retarded they are and you
know the great thing that him is he has
got great sense of humor and british men
really do they can really see the joke
they really laugh at themselves so he
doesn't mind you know I there's
something in there where I say and it's
true i gave him as a present a couple
years ago a new yorker cartoon IE can
order them from the cartoon bank and I
had it blown up and it's one of the ones
with the guy lying in the shrinks couch
and he's a businessman he's got his
little briefcase and he's saying to the
shrink you might say that I'm in denial
but I really feel that my personal life
is none of my own damn business and that
was really how Robert my husband feels
he does not want to talk about it but he
thinks it's funny so it's okay